Okay, I'm going to be honest. AI
companies have a set amount of computing
power. And at the moment, they are
spending more of it on scaling up
money-making stuff like browsers and
video shorts than on scaling up frontier
performance and IQ points. Hence the
feeling among some of a slowdown in
progress and no hard feelings. You got
to make the investors some money. But as
that maxes out, the story will shortly
hopefully return to ramping up Frontier
Intelligence. For example, when Gemini 3
comes out from Google DeepMind, expected
in the next 2 months, but none of what I
just said means that pretty juicy things
aren't happening with our current
language model horsepower. So, I'm going
to start with a novelty produced by a
baby LLM. Then I'll get to a revealing
remark from a top OpenAI researcher and
end with some interesting bits that I
found throughout this week. Let's start
with a language model so often decrieded
for their hallucinations, but one that
actually is pushing science forward by
learning the language of biology. Yes,
the model does have a dodgy name, C2S
scale, but it was able to generate a
novel hypothesis for a drug to aid in
cancer treatment. What I'm going to try
and do is simplify the simplification of
this 29page paper. So here we go. When I
say we have a language model that
generated a novel hypothesis for a drug
to aid in cancer treatment, what I mean
is it was a drug candidate that was not
in the literature for being able to help
in this way. This model by the way was
based largely on the openw weightights
Gemma 2 architecture from Google
released over a year ago. Gemma 3 has
come out since. Gemma 4 is due any time.
So it's not the latest Gemma by any
stretch. But anyway, this language model
was given special doggy training. You
can think of it. Reinforcement learning
rewards for accurately predicting how
cells would react to drugs, especially
regarding interferon. I know what you're
thinking. But why would we do that
though? Well, it's to make cold cancer
tumors hot. In other words, to make them
detectable by the immune system. Wait,
so hold on. This is an LLM that can
speak biology. Yes. And English, too.
Like, you could probably likely still
chat to this model about football.
Anyway, C2S scale turns each cell's gene
activity into a short sentence, if you
like. So, a large language model can
read biology like it does text. Slightly
more technically, it can find drugs that
reliably amplify the effects of
interferon conditional on there already
being some of it present but just not
quite enough. In other words, it learns
to predict how the immune system will
respond to a drug. A bit like how it
might learn how an author will continue
a sentence. Now, just quickly on the
name, it's called C2S scale. And the
authors say scaling the model to 27
billion parameters yields consistent
improvements. In case you're not aware,
that's still easily five or 10 times
smaller than the models some of us will
work with every day. I totally get that
there are going to be cynics in the
audience, but this is not like those GP5
surfacing existing breakthroughs
stories. If you don't know about that
controversy, I won't bore you with it,
but this is quite different. The drug
candidate, which I'm going to butcher,
Sil Mittertib, was not linked anywhere
in the literature for having this
capacity. As the authors write, this
highlights that the model was generating
a new testable hypothesis and not just
repeating known facts. Even better, by
the way, you're probably wondering, it
worked on human cells in a dish. Aka,
the model's incilico prediction was
confirmed multiple times in vitro in the
lab. Obviously, I do have to clarify at
this point though that it wasn't
confirmed on actual human beings. that
alas will take years and years of
testing as is the way in medicine. But
before we leave this story, just imagine
with me for a moment this drug being
used in concert with others for more
effective cancer treatment in just a few
years, directly inspired by a language
model. That's wild. As the paper's
authors say, this result also provides a
blueprint for a new kind of biological
discovery. Now, just as I am filming
this video, I have noticed that Google
has published this story in nature on
quantum computing. And some of you may
have thought that the video's title was
about that. But note, they say that it's
paving a path towards potential future
uses in drug discovery. That's
incredible and that's all going to
change the world in the coming decades.
But this C2S is pretty remarkable right
now. Just remember these stories when
people say that LLMs will not accelerate
science. Now, it would be pretty lazy of
me to just write the narrative that this
shows that OpenAI is falling further
behind, especially when you get reports
that Gemini 2.5 Deep Think has just hit
record performance on Frontier Math.
That's pretty much the hardest benchmark
around for mathematics. But actually, on
Raw Intelligence, I don't think OpenAI
is that far behind. And I don't just
mean on for example my own benchmark
simple bench where I finally got around
to testing Gypsy 5 Pro and it snuck in
just under Gemini 2.5 Pro. I know I know
you guys would want me to test deep
think but there's no API for that. So
for now you've got this comparison. If
you don't know Simple Bench is about
testing the question behind the question
kind of like trick questions you could
think of it with some spatio temporal
questions thrown in. No, I mean I think
I've spent over a 100 hours testing G65
within Codeex and it's just frankly
better than any of the alternatives.
Definitely compared to those from Google
and yes, even compared to the brand new
Clawude Code. I do love how you can use
Clawed Code on your mobile. I think
that's epic. Thank you, Anthropic. But
it wasn't just that on one of the first
queries I had for clawed code, it
attempted to delete a key section of
code completely randomly. That's of
course just anecdotal. I mean you could
get the outputs from clawed code ask
about it in GC5 codeex and vice versa
and far far more often claude code will
say oh yeah I'm wrong sorry codeex is
right and that is borne out in testing
too and remember coding is anthropic
specialty so openai are really cooking
with codeex that's what I mean when I
call openai a beast that is currently
choosing to spend its set amount of
compute on money-making activities like
Sora now I'll come back to Sora in a
moment but It's time for the second
story that I found really interesting in
the last few days that I think many
people missed. And the story isn't just
that we got a paper by a bunch of famous
AI authors proposing a final conclusive
definition of AGI. I say with a rising
tone because I don't think it is
actually a conclusive definition of AGI.
But no, that isn't quite the story,
though it's part of it. The story comes
with a link from this paper to something
that a top open AAI researcher recently
revealed. But first, what's this paper?
Well, basically it's an answer to what
many of you have asked for for a long,
long time, which is giving a definition
of AGI. And the big anchor that the
paper proposes is this theory of
cognitive capacity, the cattle horn
carroll theory. It's called the most
empirically validated model of human
cognition. So they basically take what
has been proven to assess human
cognition and then apply it to models.
One of the big headlines is that the
resulting AGI scores are GPT4 at 27%,
GPT5 at 58%. Kind of makes it sound like
just with the same architecture going up
to GPT6 or 7, you'd get to AGI, but
that's not what the paper says. The
theory breaks cognition down into 10
discrete categories that have survived
as factors of cognition for over a
century of research. They do not, by the
way, include physical dexterity. So
that's one huge caveat. Each category is
given an equal 10% waiting on the AGI
score out of 100. So for example,
reaction time is treated as equally
important to general knowledge. So we
have general knowledge and it's
definitely true that models know a lot
more than they used to. Reading ability,
I think it's pretty fair to say models
have come a long way. Maths ability.
Well, we just saw how Gemini Deepth
think is breaking records on Frontier
math benchmarks. On the spot reasoning
is a bit more hazy. It's kind of a bit
like a mix of simple bench and a
traditional IQ test and a bit of theory
of mind and they give it 7%. Not sure
about that. What I mean by that is that
there are so many different ways of
testing induction like ARC AGI 1 which
yields amazing scores for GC5 and then
ARC AGI 3 where it performs terribly.
Traditional theory of mind in which the
models ace those tests but then
perturbed where you just change a few
words and they fall right down. Then
there's working memory and long-term
memory storage. And that's where things
get really weird. Language models can't
remember things, or at least they can if
they're within the context of the
conversation, but not beyond that. They
don't continually learn things on the
job as it were. And that's the key point
I'm going to come back to with a quote
from OpenAI. Then there's a metric on
hallucinations which again is quite hard
to pin down and visual processing that
is rapidly improving as you might have
seen with the recent Deepseek paper.
Rounding things out we have listening
ability and reaction time essentially
speed. Don't know about you but models
can in general do things much much
faster than me. But the one that stands
out is lacking memory. The authors say,
"Without the ability to continually
learn, AI systems suffer from amnesia,
which limits their utility, forcing the
AI to relearn context in every
interaction." What I would add to that
is that because every bit of context
adds to the cost of a call to a model,
these providers deliberately limit the
amount of context that models take in.
So, they often make huge blunders
because they just don't understand the
situation. If you spent more money on
more context, they'd understand more of
the situation, but again, they wouldn't
remember it next time. One is a
fundamental limitation. One is a
question of cost. But will we soon have
a solution to the fundamental
limitation? Continual learning. Well,
that's the quote I want to get to. On
that nasty cliffhanger, I'm going to
bring you today's sponsor, a longtime
sponsor of the channel, Assembly AI, and
specifically their universal streaming
tool, because I think it's pretty epic.
Did you know how accurate these tools
have become? For example, it was only
recently that certain rival tools
couldn't understand when I said things
like GPT5 Pro. They just wouldn't get
those letters right, especially in my
accent. Now, as you can see, they handle
it flawlessly. I think that's
incredible. And the link to this, by the
way, is going to be in the description.
I follow AI relentlessly and of course
test almost everything that comes out.
And I didn't know these tools had gotten
this good, frankly. That was also really
fast. I don't know if you noticed that,
but anyway, link in the description.
Now, on that quote, this is OpenAI's VP
of research, Jerry Tuar. I think it's
his first interview, but he mentioned
something quite crucial around 58
minutes. But first, some context before
we even hear from him. What are some of
the obvious limitations of continual
learning? Well, the model providers
wouldn't be in control of what the
models were learning. Like imagine GPT6
truly understands your app from the
ground up or maybe your exam from the
ground up. Then on the job, it bakes
that into its weights so you never have
to tell it again. And that's amazing,
right? But if we do that naively, then
you can imagine all kinds of sick things
that people train the models to learn.
>> Is there a concept of um uh I guess
online RL that that happens where as the
agent does something and learns from the
real world. Uh the RL happens in in real
time. So in general like all all of RL
is happening like most of RL that that
you hear talk to uh language models is
online but it's done online in a way
that is still a training run. It's still
being trained like kind of separately
from the user. There have been a few
models in the world and I've I've
learned recently that I think I think
cursor uh is trying to train some models
online with their with their users in
the loop and it's theoretically possible
to train models in GPT or every other
product just just responding to the
users and reinforce through whatever
whatever rewards you get in there. But
this is not what I am aware at least
like not not what opening is doing at
the moment and it is it's can be great
but it can be also dangerous because you
are not really very much controlling
what you are reinforcing in that loop
and what's what could what could happen.
So yeah at least until until we have a
really good safeguards I don't think I
don't think we should try to do that in
anything like as as as complex and large
scale as just GPT. Let me know in the
comments if you can see an obvious way
around that limitation. I hope I've at
least convinced you that we live in
pretty weird and unpredictable times
when it comes to AI. And so I want to
end on this note. Did you know that Sora
2 can answer benchmark level questions
as a video generator? As in you could
ask it a complex multi-choice
mathematical or coding question and it
would answer in the video scoring really
well. Yes, not quite as well as a
focused model, but I think that's wild.
Doesn't that kind of show you the
physics calculations that these video
generators are doing on the fly? Anyway,
that's all from me. Let me know if
you're loving the new browser from
ChatBT. I'm still going to give it a bit
more time before I mention it properly
in a video just to see if it's worth
talking about. Obviously, do let me know
your early thoughts, too. But, thank you
most of all for watching all the way to
the end. And I know it's been a while
between videos. I really am hoping to
ramp things up in November.